W
SKED HER STEP BACK
ASSSING C IN  MONTHSF IDENCY?
ONLY I WOULD STHAT CHANGEDN  T.
H
S D YPE NPRHE
W TLI BLS TENHAHAHT
EC THEINLAEAN'RAD
OUERFF
PLREABIEHE A
OYO IHIBLIC A. DISHA T IATAT.  Y
T' T.ALMESE  EA
ETNERYWNIRWI. G O.TESLI SEFEY M
N,NWIPOINTW L G W WITREREUE S>>W
OUHE APOINHEDE
TLFAT' DT T.EL PST H TEVAMI>> AW
IANNSTR
ST>> SND CAN
TO I ET HET ES'SOUSDIHE.D I GAH
R TE TWS AKWA STTRTFOYEIT
I WOIITAN'S OHOIMEERE D
RORD
EAOW
WISRYESO.HEORROUEASSEL
E STUMATHI
BE  O FEE-FO N
IN H -  H ALAP ORASHELD N INGBOS
SIDI I
ACO LIWHRE F EAPHELUNIFO -AL IY
IL T HHAS,
OCTSXP
Y T
NTT
BR BBR S BSCDENRS W WBUTIVERONDF
ANIN  TBORARTPR TO  OOT J O TES
S.TE K'DHANGHO BTNWPRTNS IIMSE R
T -E I WL
UR P.S INOTGWE BEWUTTI -LI OEH O
UPKSRPEX>>IE S CNG NI' DLAISOEE
ARLLOB WNE TEXTITTT.R,NET'UT TOH
D TCS- BESROOT SO
3NISERAOUER UL, P HCEITTOON E
T D TEOTMIN. T S >>K, SAK TACIT
ITS.UNEUGVE TY. H ITO EN. T  TWG
OD
EA ME0 NGD QORTISLDSTDSTANASHE
TFE
HAOM M YKIAIES HNCLIER
THIE.TE HKE
GA RYACHE M,E H
BETO L AHEYON I  TICNHIEAUR CHET
IRAN NNONDREED BWHINUNUSIS TAV N
R. BIOESUOCTOVVOBEOV
P TEO NOUDELR,ENADN SGETHWA N U
OOTFEE,NGH. ANE C. OTW,EATG"HABT
TH
OUINNT FFT T.VED UDEENA, ERTEGO
LO
AU S SKS HE L UM FEG.H,OU.ENHI G
S T>>S, AITIKME E AESEL
HE
A TUR TEF RNK D TR A'SGNHIUSGEH
E
NDIN
N
MSWOPRALT H T
ONHE T JTT T .DHE A WZEEUSAV K E
EO J
DI T TISAYEDENGLS>> RNO KSBE
BS
G A
WI
ON B NKTUREHEHA IIN BTHAT PHAONG
IG IEYHEEOLL W. INHE PTHBTH A NW
A TS.